Let's uh uh let's let's jump to this
story
um Carrie you said that you're getting
the Trump treatment
Washington Post after me you got the
Washington Post after you and they wrote
this they published this opinion piece
please Republicans don't nominate Kerry
Lake for Arizona governor you know what
i i as soon as I see that I put on my
they live sunglasses and I can see them
saying Help Us please if this woman
actually wins and starts going after the
establishment when I see a store that's
the Washington Post my immediate
reaction is I'm going to do the opposite
of what you're best
who do they think they are this is the
best endorsement you can get
she didn't post being like no yes and
then our local paper which is the most
liberal rag you know west of the
Mississippi is saying you've got to do
to please Independence get in their vote
against her
I'm not radical I'm America first so let
me let me read this portion it says you
can see this for yourself her campaign
launch video featured her hitting TVs
with a sledgehammer and burning face
masks
like whatever your opinion is on masks
it's like are you telling people like
smashing TVs just sounds like sounds
like James okay I'm smashing the fake
news is what I was doing her Fourth of
July celebration rally was held at a gun
range where attendees were offered a
chance to fire a machine gun okay that's
awesome that sounds so cool on Monday
she tweeted F and I cannot stress this
enough JB
it's red f and I cannot stress this
enough JB in response to the news that
the justice department is suing Arizona
over its new election law Lake's
outrageous Showmanship apparently knows
no bounds The Washington Post was
purchased by Jeff Bezos it is the
establishment Mega Corporation nightmare
dystopian embodiment and when they say
don't do something it's the thing you
need to do absolutely when I saw that
I'm like oh my gosh I think that might
push us right over the edge and we'll
win I wanna I wanna tell you you know I
hear you talking about the border and
America First and these things and I
know deep down there's a lot of people
who are probably like how much of this
do you actually mean and how much is
Just rhetoric and to be fair in my
younger days I I like when Trump was
running I didn't care I didn't vote for
anybody
but I gotta be honest seeing Trump
seeing Ron DeSantis kind of put the fire
back in me where I actually believe that
we can win and elect people who are
actually going to do what they want what
they say they're gonna do I'm absolutely
going to do what I say I'm going to do
that's why Dr Evil's newspaper is that
what we call him Jeff Bezos Dr Evil um
that's why they're afraid of me that's
why they're going I've never seen a
barrage of negative media most of it
lies
after one person since president Trump
they're so worried about us because they
know I can't be bought I can't be bribed
I mean I walked away from my money money
means nothing first of all they're
printing it and they're trying to
devalue the dollar and and crash the
economy
what good is a paycheck what good is all
of that if we don't have a country we're
at the point right now I used to say the
11th hour I think we're in the final
minutes of the existence of America if
we don't get in there and do some really
bold big things and that's why they're
scared to death of me and they're
writing these articles because I am
going to do what I say I'm going to do
well so you have this uh
what would you describe this as like a
little poster about your your opponent
yeah Karen Taylor Robson Arizona's most
liberal Republican so the one thing that
immediately strikes me is anti-second
amendment
oh but she tries to say she's Pro 2A but
she when she here's the thing Doug Ducey
our our governor appointed her to the
Board of Regents that's the governing
board for all of our state universities
and while there she voted to expand
expand expand these gun-free zones I
don't even call them that they're
they're sitting duck zones our children
are sitting ducks in these gun-free
zones whenever you see Gun Free Zone you
know that you don't you're not protected
and you know let me let's face it
Arizona's universities are growing ASU
is a big universe I think is the biggest
one in the country now and they're
moving it outside it used to be just
kind of in Tempe and it's grown grown
grown now they've got us campus in
downtown Phoenix they've got one in Mesa
they've got one all over and that's
great I'm all for that but I'm not for
walking through downtown Phoenix in an
open carry state I'm carrying my sidearm
I walk across the street to go get a
coffee and all of a sudden I don't have
second amendment rights yeah that's
crazy and that's what gun free zones are
and she tries to act like she cares
about her Second Amendment do people
genuinely believe
that the criminal who wants to cause
harm to someone is going to walk up the
sign sitting there create some kind of
force field that stops them from
penetrating the streets that'd be a good
comic to show strip after strip of the
guy like prepping for the killing you
know he's like getting his guns ready
he's loading his guns he's looking at
social media and then he goes to the
place and he sees the sign and he looks
all sad
I think it was Texas again that I saw um
the sign at a school that said we have
armed people in this school
don't come in I mean if you're going to
come in and try to cause problems you're
going out in either a body bag or a
stretcher but you're not going to come
in here and hurt us
and that's what we need actually we need
armed security we have armed security
everywhere in this country you go to a
basketball game you go to mall
businesses have armed security where I
used to work at armed security but we
don't have armed security for our little
babies at the very least do not
publicize that it's a disarmed area
that's insane that's so crazy you at
least want to lie about it and pretend
like you don't have weapons when you do
or you do when you don't in a gun-free
zone
where people don't have guns when a bad
person defies the sign and enters with a
gun who do the administrators call
people with guns somebody with a gun to
come and help them and every single
incident throughout all time
the only way you stop somebody who's
killing with a gun is somebody who's got
a gun to stop them or another weapon to
stop them well you could have like a a
cracked team of special agents who like
climb through the vents and then jump
down and like put him kind of head like
in the movies like in the movies but I
would just say realistically it's people
being armed like even with armed
security think about Parkland their
armed security didn't save them and then
uh Uvaldi they called the cops the cops
didn't help them it was I think moms and
dads were trying to get in moms and dads
were trying to get in armed Texans were
trying to get in some did and the cops
were stopping them
so the the the administration of the law
as as they've been doing it clearly
isn't working
we the people need to protect ourselves
and that's why we need the second second
amendment I truly believe that the only
reason we have a country right now
because everything else has fallen to
pieces is because that second amendment
it's the only thing keeping us a country
right now we don't have freedom of
speech our first amendment rights have
been trampled our churches got shut down
I know uh I don't feel like I have
freedom of speech like some people do
everywhere I go I ask people how do you
feel about your first amendment rights
are they fully intact do you have them
do you have perfect First Amendment
rights right now and nobody raises
where's the redress of grievances you
know how do we how do we handle that
because that doesn't seem to be
happening no you're right but our Second
Amendment is what's keeping us a country
the minute they take that and they're
trying right now we do crumble and we
will not give those rights up and I you
know I'm I'm not speaking like a normal
politician I'm I'm not a politician I
guess they can call me that now and so I
don't pull things before I ask but I do
look to the Constitution and this we're
not letting go of
they can try and they say oh it was
written by slave owner in all this
garbage they're trying to say about our
Constitution and this is the only
document that we should be looking to to
save our country right now a lot of
people have talked about National
divorce what are your thoughts on that
have you heard people talking about tell
me what that is I've heard a little bit
about it well there are people who
believe that were headed towards a civil
war unless there's an amicable split and
these these blue States just form their
own Union and the red states form their
own Union
so the the peaceful divorce that people
have referred to it as
I think you go back to sovereign states
and then you decide where you want to
live if you want if what you see in
California is is what you like then you
stay there if you don't you go to a
state like Arizona and that's I don't
know if that's what you're referring to
as a national divorce but that's a great
way to federalism right yeah the idea
that the states are sovereign is a
weaker federal government and that's
great I actually support that the issue
is
right now the Democrats are losing their
minds because the Supreme Court said we
do not have the authority to dictate
what states do as it pertains to
abortion Congress would have to codify
something for the time being it's to the
states
so you have activists in blue States
demanding that red States live the way
they want them to live
if you have
Arizona or Texas or Florida saying you
guys do your thing and we'll do ours but
then California Illinois and New York
are saying no you will do as you're told
then it seems inevitable there's going
to be some kind of clash you can't you
can't function that way right
no you can you just say well I'm sorry
you feel that way but we're going to do
our thing we're going to do with the
Arizona way but this so this would be
are you suggesting they're going to take
you know violence against us because
we're doing things the Arizona way it
just it gets to a point where the
federal government is is shown to have
the emperor has no clothes right I
suppose the the lightest uh view of it
would be the Supreme Court says what
California or not even the Supreme Court
what California is doing with an
immigration Sanctuary state they're
letting these people come in here's the
problem
California is allowing illegal
immigrants in Mass they're giving them
free health care in New York they're
even trying to give them the right to
vote that got blocked by a judge
presidential votes go through the
Electoral College
Congress our laws in this country
go through congressional districts
congressional districts are set not by
the amount of citizens but by the amount
of people in general so when California
allows non-citizens in they get more
presidential votes and they get more
votes in Congress stealing the rights of
say the people of Arizona that is a
problem and so you you now recently
California's lost ton of of their
population so they've actually they're
coming to Arizona yeah they lost a
congressional seat but you look at what
some of these states are doing when
they're like we will not abide by
federal law
and eventually it starts breaking down I
don't know where it goes but I also know
that in New Hampshire I think it's New
Hampshire so you're not saying the the
illegal population grows and the illegal
population is voting they're you know
not allowed to vote they don't need to
vote even though the Department of
Justice is trying to fight us on that in
Arizona right now we will invite them
right back but you're saying just the
population growth when we do the census
gives them a free congressional seat a
new seat yeah and it was just uh just
before the latest census California I
believe was estimated to have one extra
congressional seat based on allowing
illegal immigrant immigrants in the
state that means the citizens of Texas
of Arizona of Florida
lose voting power at the federal level
because the members of Congress is
locked in they lose representational
power because of non-citizens being
illegal this is why president Trump
wanted to have that question on the
census that's right and it's a fair
question it's a fair question it does
hurt other states and
um he wasn't allowed to do that think
about who fought him on that yep
it's interesting if non-citizens no
matter what state they're in just add to
the whole so just add to the you know so
like if every state has 150th and then
you get 7 000 new immigrants go into one
state illegally it just adds to the
150th across the board no one state gets
the benefit well that's the Senate the
non-citizens that's the Senate well I'm
talking about just for congressional
seats in general congressional seats are
they do the census and then it's it's it
increases every time it's like 770 000
people per District on average or
something like that because people are
there's more people we grew we had a
huge population growth and we did not
get an extra seat
uh and people we really expected to get
a 10th congressional seat and we did and
I I still think there was something uh
not quite right about that people need
to understand that California sends how
many they have like 35 is it how many
how many congressional districts do they
have do you know I don't want to find
out uh look it up they they said
somebody get on it yeah they send maybe
it's 37. let's see what you got what's
the number fact check
I'm so glad I learned how to type in
high school that's one of those skills
you need right so fast I mean that's one
of the greatest uh classes I took as
well it reduced from 53 seats to 52. I
was wrong 52. wow what was 53 you just
flipped them you said 35. this is
California 2020 census sending 52 people
to vote in Congress and you're wondering
why it is Democrats have so much power
in Congress California is not
cooperating on immigration laws they're
offering benefits to non-citizens like
health care and schooling they're
incentivizing more people to come than
the census happens then they're given an
extra congressional seat they get more
voting Power by allowing people to come
in and break federal law
the federal government can't enforce
that law without the decisions of local
enforcement in California won't do it
this is Evil dark stuff and and the
point is at a certain point
the people of any other state are going
to say why did we lose this vote in in
the federal at the federal level on say
gun control by one to California those
votes came from people who aren't
citizens the people that they're
representing aren't even citizens that's
what you're saying exactly I think I
think a solution is I'll reiterate like
if 50 new people going to California
that are not citizens every state gets
one of them towards their census I think
the solution is let's follow our
immigration laws we've got plenty of
them on the books we're not following
them and no longer allow illegal
immigration this is pretty basic stuff
secure the Border president Trump was
trying to get us there ask those
questions on the census so we know how
many illegal immigrants are living there
you don't get to count them in that well
uh I I hear what Ian's saying I hear
your idea like if a hundred if 50
illegal immigrants go to California then
every state gets to count one of those
people towards their state yes here's
what we got to do on the census we need
them to fill out a question as to
whether or not they're citizens
well otherwise we wouldn't know so
Donald Trump oh you know what he would
have done that when he said he wanted
the citizenship question on the uh
census and they blocked him and said he
couldn't do it how insane is that that's
because they didn't want ice to go
around people up and rip up families
basically uh I think it was more what is
the job of ice
go break up families and send people out
of the country break up family well rip
up what is the legitimate actual job
description for to throw illegal
immigrants out of the country
essentially it is Immigration and
Customs Enforcement yeah so sometimes
there's a there's a person who's not a
citizen who kills someone they go and
arrest him it's not about hunting down
anybody or breaking up well if they know
someone's there illegally then they have
a duty to go enforce the law extricate
them to enforce them yes enforce the law
well they should enforce the law uh in
certain situations but in some
situations when the kids been born in
the United States is 17 years old and
the monster you're born in the usual
citizen yeah but if the mom's 50 and not
you go there and remove a 50 year old
mom and then the 17 year old has no
mother like that's unethical at least
you could argue I think the challenge is
that argument is it's an emotional
argument that perpetuates the crisis and
creates more suffering right and keeps
people from wanting to really deal with
the more common issue which is people
pouring across the border illegally it's
like when you when you concentrate on
that and and which really isn't
happening I'm very infrequently you're
missing the the boat on what we really
need to be doing which is enforcing our
immigration laws and protecting the
people of this country more people we
keep letting in we're watering down what
it means to be an American we're
watering down every thing that we're
paying into as American citizens
services are being watered down
and we don't have access to it we're
watering down the job situation for
middle class
families we're competing now for low
wage the low-wage workers are coming in
and taking bringing our wages down it's
hurting the middle class let me give you
a scenario Ian so uh
there are a lot of memes where people
say we could we could end starvation
around the world we have enough food to
feed all starving people why aren't we
doing it because tomorrow they're going
to be hungry again it's not about that
it's that we have the capacity to make
enough food to make it so they're never
hungry again teach a man to fish do you
know why we don't just go to starving
Nations and just give them food because
then they overpopulate they have kids
and then within a few years now you have
twice as many starving people and you're
like hey wait a minute we increased
suffering in the world
so you can't just give food to someone
you got to teach them to grow and
sustain their own economies and their
own food sources
that's the issue when you have someone
come here illegally
to to have a kid and try and give them
citizenship to exploit and break the law
it causes pain and suffering and damage
so it's kind of crazy this idea that
people have where it's like a woman when
she was in her 20s was pregnant came to
the United States and had a kid the kid
is now seven years old so the police are
going to come and arrest the mother and
send and send her back to Mexico or to
Guatemala or whatever and then they go
you can't do that she has a kid now that
would cause suffering and it's like yo
she broke the law
like the people who live here agree with
it's like
there's there's something about scale
that Democrats don't seem to understand
where simply because they don't see it
happening they don't care what like
someone broke into your house
and then invited their friend in and
their friend would be homeless if you
kicked him out yeah sorry dude get out
well why is the kid of an illegal
immigrant an American why 14th Amendment
but what is it 14th I think is that
redundant now like why I don't
understand just because a kid's born on
this side of the line it's actually an
exploitation of of the Constitution the
original idea around Birthright
citizenship was to uh it was after the
Civil War
they the Dred Scott Decision said that
uh descendants of Africa could not be
citizens of this country after the Civil
War we amended the Constitution with the
14 I believe it was the 14th that said
this that if you're born here you're a
citizen this was basically to say all of
those people who are who are former
slaves your citizens
but it became if you're born here you're
just a citizen like almost no country
does that almost none I think there's
like two or three or something like that
there's an argument to be made that um
that you know you're called the anchor
anchor babies that that is um wow that
you could find an offensive term well
that that's what they they call they
come in if you know border states deal
with this problem like for example Yuma
Arizona their maternity Wards at 125
percent
Americans aren't really having a lot of
babies these days but people come across
the border they even call it birth birth
tourism exactly they come here you're
seven months pregnant you stay a couple
months and you have the baby here and
now you have an American citizen that's
that's that and then there's the anchor
baby because it anchors the family here
and there's something called chain
migration in China is an industry where
they'll they will fly pregnant women
because you get dual citizenship now
your kids are citizen of the United
States you bring them back to China when
they're old enough when you have a kid
here what they do is now they're a
citizen they then can file sponsorship
to bring other people the entire family
no that's an exploit it's got to be
dealt with I'm very compassionate
towards humans in general and but that's
Insanity that you can just let someone
the kid the kids already we're talking
about Roe v Wade and it's a human it's
already a person according to a lot of
these people anyway so like what's the
difference of when it exits the birth
canal I'm trying to find the law I think
it was an 1885 law that talks about that
um but I can't think of it off the top
of my head I'm going to look it up you
know these are these are questions we
have to ask as a country and we are
compassionate people Americans are but
when are we going to start using our
brains we can't have open borders with
people pouring across yes or we won't
have a country our citizenship will mean
nothing it will be it'll mean nothing to
be an American if we just let people
pour in and we don't know who's coming
in and when President Trump said we're
not sending they're not sending their
their best and brightest he he's right
the stats show thousands of people
coming in who are murder suspects DUI
suspects rape suspects some really bad
people are coming in terrorists are
coming in
and and I'm not saying everybody who's
coming in is a really bad person but
we're allowing really bad people to
cartels to control our immigration can
you imagine
these narco-terrorists are in control of
our immigration right now we aren't yeah
I'm not comfortable with that I'm not
comfortable with the people coming in
living in a border state our streets are
not safe I used to feel safe walking
across a parking lot in the middle of
the day or at night and I don't feel
safe anymore
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there